hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
towards the end of the second essay in
friedrich nietzsche's genealogy of
morals he discusses
a set of processes by which he says that
human beings
eventually develop fuller and fuller
conceptions
of gods deities spiritual beings that
are held to be
greater than humanity and in in relation
to which
we have a set of
duties obligations guilt
and you know in his view these are
really
projections into the social sphere into
culture accompanied by all sorts of
material artifacts and rituals
of ideal beings that
that don't really exist but in relation
to which
we orient ourselves and
you know if we think about the christian
god that he's going to talk about
we we almost can't get away from it
unless we make some
really significant efforts the vulgar
forms of atheism
as we're going to see don't really get
you completely
away from that and so this begins in
chapter 19. of the second essay
he tells us that within the original
tribal community
and so we should think about tribal
communities right we're speaking of
primeval times the living generation
always recognized a juridical duty
towards earlier generations and
especially towards the earliest
which founded the tribe
and so you know we're talking about the
living in some some respect right the
older people
but also those who have died the
ancestors
and the founders the primaval
ancestors and then he tells us that the
conviction reigns
and this is very important that it's
only through the sacrifices
and accomplishments of the ancestors
that the tribe exists so what has
demarked you
as the people or the human beings the
group that you are are the sacrifices
and the accomplishments that the
ancestors
engaged in and these are very often in
terms of legends or myths
narratives they may be reenacted in
rituals that allow the ancestors to be
in some respect present right and so the
ancestors are
really the creditors they're the ones to
whom
one owes something and what do you owe
them
well this is where it gets very
interesting
you paid the ancestors back for
their sacrifices and accomplishments
with sacrifices and accomplishments
right
sacrifices of different forms perhaps
but also by trying to do something and
nietzsche
tells us you have to pay them back with
these and we recognize a debt
now here's a key part that constantly
grows
greater why would it grow greater
well because you can never truly pay it
back
he tells us that what can you give the
ancestors
in return sacrifices initially as food
in the course of sense
feasts music honor above all
obedience for all customs as works of
the ancestors
are also their statues and commands
statutes and commands
can one ever give them enough and so
paradoxically the more that you
do pay them back the more you
reproduce a situation in which you do
have to pay them back and you're also
sending a message to
future generations some of whom are
alive and watching you
seeing you repaying the ancestors and it
becomes
a guilt it becomes something
that you're required to do if there's
consciousness of
debt as he goes on to say
and so what do we have here he says
the fear of the ancestor and his power
the consciousness of indebtedness to him
increases according to this kind of
logic
in an interesting way in
exactly the same measure as the power of
the tribe increases
as the tribe itself grows ever more
victorious independent honored and
feared
so you don't discharge the debt by
attempting to discharge the debt and
succeeding in doing the things that you
think would discharge the debt instead
you just create
more of it because you could say well
the ancestors are helping us out now
we really know that we have to sacrifice
to them right and we have more resources
that we can sacrifice
to them and for tribes or peoples or
whatever we want to call them
this gets bigger and bigger and bigger
and he also tells us every step towards
the decline of a tribe
every misfortune every sign of
degeneration of coming disintegration
diminishes fear of the spirit of its
founder and produces a meaner impression
of his cutting foresight and present
power
and so you know success
breeds more success failure breeds
distrust and more
failure and what do we see going on here
the the stronger tribes gobble up the
weaker tribes uh you know the the people
are viewed
as having been abandoned by their tribal
gods
and as he goes on he says if we imagine
this rude kind of logic carried to its
end
the ancestors of the most powerful
tribes
are bound eventually to grow to
monstrous dimensions through the
imagination of growing fear
and to recede into the darkness of the
divinely uncanny and imaginable
in the end the ancestor is transformed
into
what a god a deity right so he says
perhaps this is even the origin of god's
an origin
out of fear and he you know he's not
saying this is absolutely
uh the only way that gods can come about
but
he's saying that that this would be a a
plausible
way and then he says whoever should feel
obligated to add
but out of piety also would hardly be
right
for the greatest part of the existence
of man is prehistory
to be sure you would be quite right for
the intermediate age in which the noble
tribes developed
who indeed paid back their originators
their ancestors with interest all the
qualities that had become
palpable in themselves the noble
qualities so he's talking about here you
know the primary evaluation
and the sort of aristocratic morality
attributing to those gods
all these great things nietzsche is not
talking about what we could call
catholian gods or
or gods of commoners either but you know
you can see what's going on here in a
lot
of religious developments
then he says something new happens
as well and this is
in section 20. it says history shows the
consciousness of being in debt
to the deity did not come to an end with
the organization
of communities on the basis of blood
relation so you know at first we've got
tribes clans whatever you want to call
them
that are connected by some sort of blood
relation and
then we see societies expanding as they
become more successful
they start taking in other people they
may you know enslave
or overthrow other people bring them in
other people
might be attracted to their success
come in as immigrants and now we have a
multi let's call it multi-ethnic or
multi-uh
tribal society and what happens there
he says even as humans inherited the
concepts good and bad from the tribal
nobility
right it also inherited along with the
tribal and family divinities
the the burden of still unpaid debts and
the desire to be relieved of them so
you take on the gods of the people who
you live among you inherit the family
and the tribal gods and then they cease
being family and tribal gods
they become the gods of the city they
become the gods of
the country they become the gods of the
larger uh more you know
what we call it complex people
and along with that goes this burden of
debt
and the desire to be released from debt
and he goes on and he says that
the transition is provided by those
numerous slave and dependent populations
who whether through compulsion or
through civility and mimicry adapted
themselves to the masters
cult of the gods this guilty feeling of
indebtedness continued to grow for
several millennia
always in the same measure as the
concept of god and the feeling of
divinity increased on earth and was
carried to
the heights and you know he talks about
different peoples struggling against
each other the entire history of
ethnic struggle victory reconciliation
fusion
everything that precedes the definitive
ordering of rank of the different
national elements
in every great racial synthesis is
reflected
here's a very interesting idea in the
confused genealogies of their gods in
the sagas of the gods struggles
victories and reconciliations
and so what is he saying there is that
the stories the narratives the myths
are reflecting this process of
accumulation
of gods of bringing them together and
it's going to be messy it's going to be
confusing it's not going to
all make perfect sense right because
this process
itself is complex he says the advance
towards universal empires
is always also an advance towards
universal divinities despotism with its
triumph over the independent nobility
prepares the way for some kind of
monotheism well this is a very
interesting idea isn't it and we can
look at a lot of different religions and
say well they're not strictly
monotheistic but
you know there's certainly a god who's
on top well that would be reflective of
what nietzsche is talking about here
now he goes on and he talks about
christianity
and a little bit of its aftermath in a
christian
europe that is you know
de-christianizing itself
in the time of nietzsche and he
suggests that the christian god is in a
certain way
a maximal god so far
it is the most successful of these gods
you know spread
all over the earth he says uh it was it
was
the advent of the christian god was
therefore accompanied by the maximum
feeling
of guilty indebtedness on earth
and then he suggests that
we've gradually entered on the reverse
course there's no
small probability with the irresistible
decline of faith in the christian god
there's also a considerable decline in
mankind's feeling of guilt
he says that atheism and a second kind
of second innocence
belong together uh the prospect cannot
be dismissed that the complete and
definitive
victory of atheism might free mankind of
this whole feeling of guilty
indebtedness
this is a an idea that he's going to
kick around in various works also in the
third essay
and say um actually not that much right
that the the problem is of a
death of god and what we do in its
aftermath which can
still leave us with all this guilt we
just displace it in other ways
now he talks about this is in
um here we go
uh he talks uh in the in the next
section
about um what happens with christianity
itself and he tells us that this this
problematic of guilt and duty winds up
getting
turned against the debtor
so the aim he says is to preclude
pessimistically once and for all the
prospect of a final discharge
the aim now is to make the glance recoil
disconsolately from an iron
impossibility
the aim is now to turn back the concepts
guilt and duty
but back against who so you gotta well
several choices the debtor
the creditor right so the debtor who's
that well that's us
that's us human beings and so nietzsche
says that
this is where we get the notion of
something like original sin
he says uh here we go
we what you know finally they're they're
turned back
against this this debtor and we can
think about uh the beginning of the
human race the primal ancestor who is
now burdened with a curse
or of nature from whom from whose womb
mankind arose
and into whom the principle of evil is
projected now or of existence in general
and now we start to turn it against the
creditor right so
if you think about what original sin is
we can look at us oh we're all a mess
right
and then we can say well who's
responsible for this mess
well the ancestor adam adam and eve
right and then maybe kane plays a role
too
he's kind of a screw up as well or
whoever else we want
but then we can push it further back
maybe it's the devil maybe it's god
maybe it's existence itself the nature
of things and he tells us
that we can have a nihilistic withdrawal
a desire for nothingness
a desire for its antithesis for a
different mode of being
and then he tells us we stand before the
paradoxical and horrifying expedient
that afforded temporary
relief for tormented humanity that
stroke of genius
on the part of christianity and what is
that stroke of genius
a god who sacrifices
god itself in this case you know jesus
with the incarnation and the atonement
he says god
sacrifices himself for the guilt of
mankind
god himself makes payment to himself god
is the only being who can redeem
man from what has become unredeemable
the creditor
sacrifices himself for his debtor
out of love and then nietzsche jokes
around can one credit that out of love
for his debtors so this is a new advance
not only is christianity
a maximal religion in that it has a god
who's like maximally powerful
but it's also a god who does the
paradoxical
who absolves the debtor of the debt
that none other could that no effort on
the part of the debtor
could ever remove and does so through
love and then nietzsche says
okay how does this actually work
can this can this really be effective
and he says this is actually the human
being's
bad conscience that is sort of working
itself through he says
you could say that the human being could
respond and say
thank god right literally i'm
free i don't have to worry about any of
this this guilt and
i don't make any any atonement myself
this is
wonderful that doesn't really work
though
he goes on and he says the human being
still feels guilt before god he
apprehends in god
the ultimate antithesis of his own
ineluctable
animal instincts he reinterprets these
as a form of guilt before
god is hostility rebellion insurrection
and he ejects from himself all his
denial of himself his nature
naturalness and actuality and god
becomes god the judge
god the hangman but also at the same
time god the
forgiver god the lover and
at the very end of section 22 he says
all of this is interesting but also of a
gloomy black unnerving sadness so that
one must forcibly forbid oneself
to gaze too long into these abysses
here is sickness beyond any doubt the
most terrible sickness that ever raged
in man
whoever can still bear to hear how
is the in this night of torment and
absurdity there's rasana the cry of love
the cry of the most nostalgic rapture of
redemption through love
will turn away seized by invincible
horror too long the earth has been a mad
house
so this this prospect of god
absolving us of guilt through
this sacrifice that's at the center of
christianity on the part of christ
nietzsche thinks doesn't really doesn't
really acquire us what we need and as a
matter of fact
just intensifies the problematic now he
wants to
also in the next section provide us with
an alternative
whether or not this really conforms to
greek religion
is a good question but he says that we
don't actually
have to go down that path he says that
the conception of gods in itself need
not lead to the
generation of the imagination we had to
consider
that there are nobler uses for the
invention of gods
than for the self-crucifixion and
self-violation of man
in which europe over the past millennia
achieved its distinctive mastery
that is revealed by even a mere glance
at the greek
gods and i think yeah you're actually
better off if it is a brief glance
and you don't look at greek religion too
closely because then it might not map on
all that well to what nietzsche is
talking about
but he says that that we have an
alternative here um the greek gods are
reflections of what he calls noble
and aristocratic men perhaps even the
female deities
are such or perhaps we should read men
as humankind in this case
and he tells us that the greek gods are
used
here we go for the longest time these
greeks use their gods precisely so as to
ward off the bad conscience
so as to be able to rejoice in their
freedom of soul
the very opposite of the use to which
christianity put its god they went very
far in this direction the greeks these
splendid and lionhearted children
right so and there's there's another
thing that that's going along here as
well
instead of focusing on sinfulness
human beings are viewed as foolish so he
tells us
the olympian gods look at them and say
how foolish they are
he thinks when he observes the misdeeds
of mortals and foolishness folly a
little disturbance in the head
this much even the greeks of the
strongest bravest age conceded
of themselves as the reason for much
that was bad and calamitous foolishness
not
sin now it's not a complete solution he
says even this disturbance presented a
problem
how is it possible and so noble greeks
asked themselves for centuries in the
face of every incompre
comprehensible atrocity or wantonness he
must have been deluded by
a god right and he says this expedient
is
typical of the greeks that the gods
justify
human beings rather than you know
replicating this
or intensifying this dynamic of
guilt that can never be satisfactorily
discharged so you know this is some
interesting reflections on the idea
about how we human beings would come up
with
conceptions of god that could actually
draw us in generation after generation
uh you know require worship require
sacrifices require
belief and thereby influence entire
cultures
christianity being sort of like the most
successful of these
versions but one that just intensifies
the
problematic involved there
so that's that's what's going on in
essay 2.
you